la discorde autour d'une tradition
séculaire la chasse à courre aussi
appelé vénerie pour moi quand je m'en
sors tout ça je sais c'est que je perds
seulement deux journées les anti-chasse
eux sont révoltés par la traque des
proies lors de ses parties les chiens
piste l'animal le trac jusqu'à
épuisement
avant de le tuer pourquoi torturer un
animal pourquoi le traqué pendant des
heures pourquoi une organisation comme
ça autour d'un verre trois modes de
chasse et le plus écologique le plus
naturel est celui qui se rapproche le
plus de la vérité de la nature argument
contre argument de vision ne trouve pas
de points d'entente et cette situation
dure en 1976 avant la chasse le ton
monte
mobilisés contre la pratique les
militants écologistes et des riverains
joue les trouble fête
ils aspergent les chiens de naphtaline
pour troubler leur odorat et dispersent
ceux qui sont prêts à partie comme
aujourd'hui tout cela se solde souvent
par une intervention des forces de
l'ordre
1983 la bataille se joue devant un lieu
emblématique à compiègne devant le
domicile de monique de rothschild
la baronne grandes figures de la vénerie
doit faire face à des membres de la spa
et là encore dialogue de sourds
c'est aux normes adams étonnamment oui à
le voir les adulateurs les gladiateurs
c'était un gars et puis ça n'existe plus
on n'est pas identifié des
manifestations aussi à paris quelques
mois plus tard en tête de cortège bien
qu'à l'abri dans sa voiture
brigitte bardot exprime son dégoût de la
chasse à courre dans un climat de grave
au nom de
voyez demander un vrai sportif qu'il en
pense au kiosque
à en croire espère ou les sports qui n'a
pas grand mépris pour la chasse à chasse
anti chasse le refrain n'a pas de fin
seule nouveauté depuis une dizaine
d'années la guerre se joue sur le
terrain de l'image
les militants film leurs interventions
depuis 2010 est l'association ava
abolition de la vénerie aujourd'hui
diffuse des documents poignant les
autres avesnois les regarder ça la
vénerie a mauvaise presse
alors elle a elle aussi tenté de bâtir
une image 9 pour ses dix mille
pratiquants à nous d'aller d'aller vers
les gens et 2
leur faire découvrir la vénerie leurs
éléments de langage la jeunesse la
mixité sociale
une chasse plus raisonnée et moins
cruelle qu au fusil quant aux
détracteurs il leur pose toujours la
barbarie et la désuétude de la chasse à
courre
[Musique]